hello today I'm going to talk a little
about iTunes U which I just discovered
on the internet it's certainly an idea
that makes a lot of sense I've always
felt that since it's usually taxpayers
or parents or third parties who pay for
most of the cost of universities that
the lectures there should be made
available to everyone at least in the
case of the taxpayers at least and again
the best lectures and lecturers I've
never understood why in today's day and
age people were thrown to a lecture hall
to hear someone speak who may or may not
be very good when they can watch what is
now hopefully going to become the case
select from the best lecturers from the
best universities on subjects of
interest to them but as I checked
through i tunes you of course most of
the material errors video occasionally
or often with transcript and at least
for language learning and I think for a
lot of subjects I maybe I'm a minority I
prefer audio and transcript I don't want
to sit there and watch someone for an
hour on my computer screen or in my on
my little iPod I would rather take the
sound and listen to it while I'm doing
other things and and then it particular
it's a language I want to read the text
then and save words and phrases the way
we do on link and if I take the example
of a promise fee which I'm listening to
now every day I download three or four
interviews or discussions or monologues
from echamos be in Russian which I then
listen to on my ipod and I have access
to the text which I can then import and
I can save words and build up my
vocabulary in link there are so many
sites CBC
international NHK and others which only
provide the audio with no transcript it
would be great if more of these sites
provided the the transcript as well
where I was in the lookout here at link
for sites that have audio and transcript
so that we can direct our learners there
our learners can import these into our
system for their own use obviously if
there are copyright issues we can't
share them with other members but to me
this is the ideal material and if I were
studying learning about history or other
subjects I will I think even in my own
language i refer audio and text the
video is like entertainment it's a
little bit of spice yeah who is you know
who is Steve Kaufman let's have a look
at his face every now and again at at
this economically for example one of the
people whose prominent there is
Alexander venediktov and so I listened
to him rant for 20 minutes 40 minutes or
interview people or answer questions
that have been submitted by their
listeners but if he puts up a two-minute
video I will occasionally look at it but
not that often and and
if I see him talking I am less connected
to the words than if I just have the
audio I don't have anything else to go
on with the audio I just have to try to
listen to the words and from a language
learning perspective and I would even
think from other perspectives you know
I've listened to audio books now French
is the language that I speak very well
but I enjoy audio books I envision I've
tried to imagine the scene I cling to
the words for the meaning if I see the
video I can't concentrate I lose
interest so and yet a lot of people want
video I've even had people say can be
produced more video for link so that i
can say so that i can see your mouth
move in english and that it helps me in
the pronunciation which i don't agree at
all and particularly in youtube were so
often the the mouth seems to be a little
bit out of sync with the words or the
sound so you know I'm just curious what
people say out there I mean why this
fascination with videos I like watching
movies i watch movies in Russian it's
entertainment it makes it all more real
in a way it's kind of like a reward I
look forward after having done a fair
amount of studying of rushing through my
listening and reading activities then I
go back and watch him a video again that
I haven't seen for a while and I'm
always happy when I find that I
understand more than I did before so
it's an entertainment it's a for mental
game and its reward but it's not the
main learning medium to me to me is
audio and text and transfer so maybe I'm
just a purist or maybe I'm completely
wrong or maybe I'm the exception but
that is that is the way I see it so I
look forward to hearing you